Now that you've tried out the watch
face sample code, it's time to do
a deep dive to understand the different
parts of making a watch face.
If you look at the project
in Android Studio,
you'll see it shares a lot in common
with a regular Android Wear App
in that it has a phone project
application and a wearable project.
So they're built into an APK in
the same way as a wearable app.
You can even bundle a watch
face in with an existing app or
multiple watch faces into the same
APK like we're doing here.
However one key difference is that
watch faces are actually a service,
they're not activities.
If we look at DigitalWatchFaceService,
you'll see that it extends
CanvasWatchFaceService.
You will also see that we
define an Engine class
which extends
CanvasWatchFaceService.Engine.
These classes are both defined
in the Wearable support library
that you've seen earlier.
The first method of
interest is onCreate,
which is called to
initialize your service.
The first thing we do is
call setWatchFaceStyle, and
provide a builder of the attributes
that we want to set for our watch face.
You can see that we've selected
variable size PeekCards here.
We also only want PeekCards to show for
interruptive notifications and
finally we disable the SystemUiTime
since our WatchFace is doing it's
own time representation for us.
The next part of onCreate
is initializing resources.
It's very important that you do
as much of your allocation and
initialization here as possible.
So setting paint styles and loading and
resizing large bitmaps
should be done here.
You definitely don't want to be doing
expensive operations in the main
draw code for your watch face.
Nor allocating and
freeing objects since that will cause
the refresh performance to suffer.
The next step is the onTimeTick method.
This method is called in
ambient mode once every minute.
This is the only time that Android
wear will call you code to update your
watch face.
We'll talk more about
faster updates later.
When your on time tick is called,
you need to invalidate the canvas.
This tells the framework that your
canvas needs to be redrawn, and
this is done in the onDraw method,
which will be called later.
The onDraw method is where all
the drawing happens for your watch face.
You need to run this code very
quickly since it'll be called a lot.
So hopefully, you did all your
prep work earlier in onCreate.
You can see that we start by setting
our pre-created calendar object to
the current system time.
Then we start drawing things.
We filled the background
with a solid color.
And then use the bounds object
to provide the dimensions.
You should always use the bounds object
to calculate the width, height, or
center of the display, and
it will work properly even on devices
with an inset chin at the bottom.
This is important in an analog watch
faces where the hands must come
from the center of the display.
The canvas object has many methods for
drawing, drawRect here draws rectangles,
drawText draws text for you.
You can control how this drawing is
done with the paint object provided as
the last argument.
These were configured in onCreate.
You'll notice this use
of isInAmbientMode.
This is used to decide whether we'll
render the seconds value, or put AM or
PM afterwards when in ambient mode.
Here we have
the onPropertiesChanged method.
This method is called to provide to you
information about very special display
support that you might
need to implement.
You can see here
PROPERTY_BURN_IN_PROTECTION.
We do not use bold font on
displays that have burn-in issues,
since the thick text will be wider
than the shifting pattern applied
to move the watch face around.
You can see here we call
setTypeface to implement this.
And here we have
PROPERTY_LOW_BIT_AMBIENT.
This tells us if the display can
only render simple colors when
in low power mode.
So what else is happening for
interactive versus ambient mode?
The onAmbientModeChanged method is
called whenever a switch is made
between modes.
In the code, you can see it's
changing the paint styles so
they have different colors
depending on the mode we're in.
We also detect if the watch
supports low bit mode.
If it does we toggle the anti
aliasing flags since that is
not allowed on these
watches in ambient mode.
In here we call invalidate to
force a refresh after the change.
Otherwise we'll be stuck with
the previous display and
will not match the mode we just entered.
Finally you will notice
an updateTimer call.
This is important because we need to
refresh the watch quickly when in
interactive mode but
once permitted in ambient mode.
Let's go to the definition
of mUpdateTimeHandler.
You can see we defined
a Handler earlier.
We call invalidate to
force a refresh and
then decide if we should
schedule another update later on.
If we do, we set an update to occur
in a fixed number of milliseconds.
If we follow the dependency, we can
see it as NORMAL_UPDATE_RATE_MS and
this 0.5 seconds.
So the CP will sleep between updates.
The code is written in
onDraw to draw colons for
the first half of each second,
giving a blinking effect.
If you look at other samples
like the Suite Watch Face,
it does not use a timer, and just calls
in validate directly from onDraw.
This uses a lot more CPU power, but
gives smoothly moving watch hands.
Some of the other interesting
features are support for time zones.
We register a broadcast receiver so
that our service will be notified
when we change time zones.
This happens more often than you think,
such as when our user arrives
in a new city on an airplane.
You can see the code changes the time
zone of our calendar object.
It then calls invalidate so that Android
will refresh the clock immediately.
Android Wear automatically propagates
the time zone change that the phone
discovered to the wearable.
So what we need to do is
register the broadcast receiver
to find out when other
changes have been made.
The time zone is retrieved here
with the getDefault method.
One other thing to note is that you'll
also need to deal with any localization
issues such as drawing the time and date
appropriately for different languages.
In the same way that you'd have to deal
with this on Android phones and tablet's.
Let's now go to onDataChanged.
You'll notice that this service
implements a listener for
changes in data items, just like
we talked about for wearable apps.
This is designed to handle updates
from the configuration activities and
change the UI to reflect
the desired colors.